I think nobody will be surprised if I say
that immigration is one of the most important
issues in international politics...
And certainly, both in Europe and the United
States, lately everything related to this
issue takes over most of the news and front
covers.
Without going any further, here in VISUALPOLITIK
we’ve already spoken a few times about this
subject… and we’ll soon post a special
video, first on Patreon and then here on YouTube,
commenting – and dismantling – many of
the myths, and half-truths that exist on this
subject.
By the way… before we continue.
Thank you.
Thank each and every one of you for your support,
we just surpassed the 480.000 subscriber mark.
So really, thank you very much...
but, before proceeding with the video, I want
to give a special thanks to all of you who
are supporting us on Patreon.
Thanks to you we’ve already managed to publish
50% more videos, and now we’re preparing
many surprises and, of course, all the other
things that we’ve promised you.
But having said that, let's continue.
My friends, this time I’d like to share
some reflections with you, some ideas... which
I think we should keep in mind when talking
about immigration.
This is particularly important if we consider
that lately mistrust, fear and anti-immigration
political speeches are very, very much alive.
(“"Get out of my country.”
I can still hear that sentence with absolute
clarity, as if it occupies a specific place
in my mind.
It’s a scar.
Deep within.
The man who said “Get out of my country”
was a Trump supporter.
I know this because he was wearing a pin identifying
the then candidate on one of his lapels.
But most of all, I know this because of the
way he said it to me.
He looked me straight in the eyes, pointed
a finger at me, and shouted.”
- Jorge Ramos, journalist of Univision and
U.S citizen who was born in Mexico.)
One of the most typical and popular arguments
of those who oppose immigration is stating
that immigrants take our jobs and take the
money they make back to their countries...
well, as long as we don’t talk about, Messi,
Cristiano Ronaldo, Nadal or Rolling Stones...
There, of course, there’s no problem.
A bit hypocritical, don’t you think?
Now, why do people decide to emigrate?
Who are these people who pack their bags and
leave their land?
Who benefits from all this movement?
In general, why is there such a negative perception
of this phenomenon?
In this video I’ll try to answer some of
these questions… but first, I think we should
take a look at how it all began…
When, why and where?
By the way, what would you say if I told you
that, in some way, you’re also an immigrant?
Listen up.
(THE ORIGIN)
From the very beginnings of humanity, people
moved.
Basically their motivation was to find food...
which forced them to move continuously from
one place to another.
Of course, back then borders didn’t exist.
The only limitation to moving from one place
to another was how far we could travel.
But, of course, all this began to change when
"modern" societies emerged, that is, when
communities settled in a particular place
where they worked to produce food, tools and
everything they needed to trade and live.
Now... one thing we can ask ourselves is...
Did the migration phenomenon disappear with
this new way of life?
Well... not at all.
See, once the first "modern" societies established
themselves in certain places and governments
began to emerge back around 3000 BC, migration
didn’t stop, although motivations did change...
Two large migration groups were created, so
to speak, two groups with very different motivations:
on the one hand, conquering, and on the other,
searching for opportunities.
The first, the conquests, were movements carried
out by societies that had achieved a higher
level of development and who wanted to take
advantage of it to gain wealth from the people
they conquered.
This involved a migratory movement from the
most developed countries to the less developed
countries to monopolize their resources.
Although this phenomenon wasn’t exclusive
to any continent, the case that we all know
best, is perhaps that of the Europeans who
managed to control almost the entire world,
starting with America.
Of course, this type of migration doesn’t
look anything like the one we have today.
The second type of migration does.
We’re talking about the peaceful mobilization
of millions of people who seek to escape their
territory of origin to reach another territory
where they can find new and better opportunities.
Therefore, in this case, their drive is to
search for economic improvements, and sometimes,
also to escape political and religious persecution.
Therefore, in general, we’re talking about
peaceful migrations from the least developed
countries to the most developed countries,
the opposite of conquests.
Well, the first large case happened at the
end of the Middle Ages, when cities grew and
people began to leave the countryside to move
to these cities.
In any case, this was a very slow process,
but everything changed with the arrival of
the Industrial Revolution.
It’s estimated that between 1850 and 1930
almost 60 million Europeans – which was
a huge percentage of the population of that
time – emigrated to the Americas, to countries
like the United States, Canada, Brazil and
Argentina.
That is to say, despite all the political
discourse against immigration, the truth is
that Europe has a well-defined history as
an emigrant territory:
Europeans, first, emigrated massively from
the countryside to the cities, then they moved
around the world and now, in our times, millions
and millions of Europeans have left their
land to live in another European Union country.
And what about the United States...
almost all of its population – if not all
– comes from other countries or lives in
territories that belonged to other countries,
as is the case of the lands of California,
New Mexico and Texas, which historically belonged
to Mexico.
So... somehow we’re all descendants of immigrants.
In fact, if we take the current anti-immigration
demonstrations to the extreme, we could state
that we are all immigrants in the regions
in which we live.
Now...
The question we can ask is, what are the consequences
of all this?
Could it have something to do with the fact
that most of the richest and most developed
countries in the world have been so exposed
to the migratory process?
Listen up.
(WHAT HISTORY TELLS US)
We’ll say it loud and clear: most immigrants
share a common goal: to achieve a better life
and progress.
It’s true, some people with deep pockets
or a good standard of living move from their
country to grow professionally, live new experiences
or just live differently.
These immigrants who usually arrive with a
full wallet almost never awaken anyone's mistrust.
However, the same doesn’t apply to those
people who are escaping hunger, misery, all
kinds of political, religious and social persecutions...
that is, immigrants who arrive with an empty
wallet in search of new opportunities.
This type of immigration is by far the most
important and, of course, the one that generates
the greatest mistrust, hostility and criticism.
However...
this immigration is almost identical to our
ancestors’: we’re talking about people
who are risking their lives and who decided
to leave everything behind - Which isn’t
easy.
And all for what?
Same as always: to achieve a better future,
to work and prosper in a lawful way
(“Little is more extraordinary than the
decision to migrate ... the accumulation of
emotions and thoughts which finally leads
a family to say farewell to a community where
it has lived for centuries, to abandon old
ties and familiar landmarks, and to sail across
dark seas to a strange land” John F. Kennedy,
President of the United States of America.)
Tell me, who built America?
Who promoted the extraordinary economic takeoff
that Argentina had at the end of the 19th
century?
Well, folks, it was the immigrants and their
descendants.
Why do we think that things will be different
today?
But of course...
when economic data shows that immigration
drives growth and development due to higher
employment levels, entrepreneurship and productivity...
then anti-immigration critics...
make up many other excuses.
We’re going to talk about them, one by one
in a future video, with data in hand... but
today I’d like to end this video reflection
with one of the most important myths: fear
and crime.
(THE GREAT CRIME MYTH)
One of the most widely differing myths is
that immigrants, especially undocumented immigrants,
the so-called "illegal immigrants", are the
ones responsible for most crimes and delinquency.
Well... you know what?
The data says the opposite.
It's true, there are legal and illegal immigrants
who commit crimes.
However, let's take, for example, a look at
what happens in the country with the most
immigrants in the world: United States.
See, between 1990 and 2013, the number of
undocumented immigrants, known as illegal
immigrants, went from 3 and a half million
people to approximately 11 million.
However, in that same period, according to
the FBI, the number of violent crimes dropped
by 48%.
Surprised?
Well, if we take the crime data into account
you shouldn’t be.
See, according to an Immigration Policy Center
study, only 1.6% of immigrant men aged 18
to 39 end up in prison.
Among those born in the United States, the
data is 3.3%, more than double.
Check out this graph on crime levels in Texas,
one of the states with the most legal and
illegal immigrants.
Yes, we can agree that we need to re-order
the migratory processes...
But stigmatizing immigrants and outlawing
their condition only favors the human trafficking
mafias.
The evidence is clear, immigrants try to reach
countries with higher levels of freedom and
more open economic systems, places, in short,
where they can work and enjoy life without
fear.
Therefore, perhaps a good measure, and maybe
the only one, to control the migratory flow
is to promote trade, private investment and
democratic institutions in the countries people
are leaving from.
But meanwhile, developed countries can take
advantage of immigration, in the same way
as other societies did throughout history.
Immigrants, my friends, want to work and prosper.
I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did and don’t forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And don’t forget, this channel is possible
because of Patreon, and our patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, thanks for watching!